Learn how to use React and TypeScript in
this excellent course from roadside coder.
This is the only video that you will need to
start building react apps with TypeScript.
In this video, we will first learn the basics
of TypeScript from absolute scratch and then
learn how to integrate them in our React js
apps by building an awesome project. We will
see how we can use TypeScript with React hooks
such as use state use ref and use reducers. How
to pass props from one component to another by
defining prop types of the component and much,
much more. But wait, what is TypeScript?
And how is it different from JavaScript?
So TypeScript is a superset of
JavaScript and is built on top of that.
According to TypeScript website, TypeScript is
JavaScript that scales, meaning it's perfect for
big projects and production grade apps. Plus it
saves you from a lot and I mean, a lot of errors.
And most of the apps that you use today are most
likely built using TypeScript. So here's the
project that we are going to build. It's called
Task fi. So this is basically our to do list app,
but much more advanced. So if I go on
and type learned, TypeScript, and choose
now we can see there are multiple icons over
here. First one is for editing icon. So let's
say learn TypeScript now and press enter.
So you can see the to do has been edited.
And we can also delete the to do by clicking on
this button. For example, if I click on this, you
can see it has gotten deleted. And we can complete
the to do by clicking on this tick mark. Or there
is another way to complete that to do to drag and
drop it inside of this Completed Tasks section.
This is an awesome feature of this app that we can
drag and drop between active tasks and completed
tasks, I included both of these ways to take mark
the two dues and drag it to the completed to do
so that you can use whichever suits you the best.
Also, you can notice if I go in and type anything
and press on Go button, you you're gonna see
a button press animation, just like this.
And you can see I've included animations on
these two dues as well when we hover on them.
So this is a really good app for beginners to
learn react with TypeScript. Also, if you're
interested in more such tutorials on React js,
be sure to check out my channel, which is called
roadside coder. Recently, I've uploaded a full
fledged myrn stack chat app tutorial series on my
channel, link will be in the description below.
So without any further ado, let's get started.
So I'll open VS code over here. And now
let's quickly go to our terminal and
initialize a new React app
with TypeScript. But wait,
we don't know how to do that. So let's go
to our browser and search react, TypeScript.
And click on this link. Since we are going to use
create react app, we're gonna go and click over
here. So it's similar to our normal react app
installation, we are just supposed to add this
dash dash template TypeScript after it. So let's
go ahead and do that. So MPX, create react app,
and the name of our app, let's say TypeScript
tutorial, and dash dash, template TypeScript,
and press enter. Now, what this will do
is it's going to go to NPM repository.
And it's going to initialize a new React app with
all of the TypeScript dependencies. And all of the
files are instead of dot j, s going to be named
at DOT TSX. So if we go back to our documentation,
this is for starting a new create react app
project. But if you have already a project that
is up and running with React and JavaScript, you
can add TypeScript by installing this npm install
TypeScript with all of the types. Here we go,
our React app has initialized now let's quickly
switch to that folder by typing cd TypeScript
tutorial. Or we can go to File Open folder.
And then open that folder. Here we go. Let's have
a look at the folder structure. So in the src,
usually, we see we have app.js over here, but now
we have app dot TSX and index dot TSX. So let's
go on and start our app by typing NPM. Start. Here
we go. Our app has started successfully. Now let's
go back to our VS code. And I'm going to remove
few of the files that we don't need. So report
five vitals setup, test logo, SVG app, dot test,
and delete. Now it's going to complain, because
it was using those files somewhere. For example,
inside of the app dot TSX. We were using logo.
So let's remove everything inside of here.
And let's just type Hello World for now.
And inside of the index dot TSX, we were using
this report web vitals. So let's remove that.
And let's see. There we go. We have hello world
written over here. But you can see it's in the
center so that we remove all of the default
styles from AB dot css. Now it's good. Now what
is this type in TypeScript? So let's go on and
understand the types that TypeScript provides us.
So let's say right over here, if I go on and
type let name equals viewshe. So in JavaScript,
what happened was JavaScript automatically decides
what the type of this variable is. So if we go on
and hover on it, we can see that type is String.
But in TypeScript, we are supposed to explicitly
define those types. So just go on over here and
type colon, and string. So this is how you define
the type of the variable. So if I go on and
remove this, and if I try to say name equals,
let's say, five, now you're going to see an error.
type number is not assignable to type string.
So this is a strict type checking, which helps
us in TypeScript. But if we go on and the abuse
See, no problem. No, let's go on and assign let h
to be a number. So we can assign it a number type.
Similarly, we have a bunch of other types as well,
such as Boolean object array, tuple, undefined,
null, and a lot of them. So just like that, let's
go on how do we assign Boolean so let's say let is
student and type boolean. So this is how we assign
it to be Boolean, Boolean can be true or false.
Now, what if we want to have a variable called
hobbies, and we want it to contain an array of
hobbies, which are basically string,
so we're going to type colon string.
And so it's going to be an array of string,
right? So we're just gonna add these braces
in front of it. Now it says that this variable can
only contain an array of strings, if it wanted to
be an array of numbers. So we can type number over
here. Now next type is called tuple. Now what is
tuple? So let's say if I go on and say, roll. So
what tuple does is tuple contains a fixed amount
of value and the types that are defined during the
declaration. So let me just go in and type number
comma string. So now what this variable can
contain, is it going to contain one number
and one string. So if I go on and say roll equals
two, I read both of the numbers. So it's going to
have a problem type number is not assignable
to type string. So this has to be a string.
So something Yeah, there we go. It's working
absolutely fine. So this is called a tuple. Now
next is for objects. How do we define an object?
So there are two ways to define an object first
is lead person our usual way we can type colon
and object. But this is not a recommended way
to do this. Because an object can have a lot
of properties inside of it, such as if I want
Person object to have a name, and age. So how do
we know that this person object contains all of
these properties. So we use something called
a type keyword or an interface keyword. Now,
don't worry, I'm going to discuss more about
this type and interface later. But for now,
an introduction, I'm going to type type. And we're
going to define the type of this person object. So
person, now it's a good practice to keep the
first letter of the types as capital. So I'm
going to type type person. And instead of it,
let me just add a name and age property. So name
is going to be a string, and age is going to be
a number. So now let's go on and assign this type
person to this type variable. So now this object
is going to contain all of the properties that
are inside of this person type. So if
I go on and equals, let's say, name,
and give it a name, let's just give it just
the name for now. Now you're going to see,
it's complaining towards that property age is
missing in this type. So this, as you can see,
this type has name property and age property.
So we are supposed to give it both of these
properties. So if I go in and give, let's say,
age, and save it, you're gonna see it's working
absolutely fine. But what if we want to make
this age property as optional? So we're just
going to go over here and add a question mark.
So this means that this property is now optional.
Now if I go on and remove it from over here, no
problem. The app is working absolutely fine. Now
what if we want to have another variable that
is going to contain an array of Person object.
So if I go and create, let, let's have a look.
So we want it to be an array of this object.
So we're just going to go over here and assign it
the type of person and array. So just like we did
up over here, if we wanted to be an array of the
person object, we can just assign it the type like
this. So you see how easy it is to assign types in
TypeScript. Now, let me remove all of this stuff.
Let me comment it out for now. Now over here,
what if we want our let's say age variable,
to be a number and string both of these, I
want it to contain both number and string.
So we're just going to use something
called union in TypeScript. So for union,
you're going to type the symbol and add another
type to it. Let's go on and assign this. So let's
say age. If I'm assigning a string, no problem,
it's working fine. If I go in and assign a number,
yep, it's working absolutely fine. All right. Now
let's see if we want to define a function, print.
Name. And what this function does is it takes a
name, and it just console logs it. So now we have
an error. So it says the name implicitly has any
type. Okay, no problem. It says this name has an
any type. So it just provided a type of string.
Now, if we go on and assign this print name,
name, then it's going to go and print that. Just
like this. But what is the way to provide a type
to a function? How do we declare a function type?
So there are two ways to define a function? One,
let's say if I go on and say, let print
name, I can provide it the type of function.
This works absolutely fine. Okay, it says
print time already been defined. Let me
just remove this for now. So this works
absolutely fine. You can use this function
type, but just like objects, there is a better
way to assign a function. So what we can do is,
we can properly define the function of how many
things it's going to contain. So let's say it,
so it takes the name. So it's going to take a
type of name, which is going to be a string,
and what is it going to return for in our case, it
wasn't returning anything. So the return type was
void. So this is how you assign the type to a
name. And don't worry, if you're having problems
understanding all of this stuff, when we go
on and create a project, then you are going
to understand all of these things in much, much
in depth. So just like this void return type,
this can have a number return type, a string
return type, a custom return type, just like this
person over here. Now what if we want this any of
these to have any value, let's say if I want the
name to have any value inside of it, not just
restricted to a string, or number or anything,
we can give it the any type. So any type
doesn't have any restriction, you can literally
keep anything inside of it. But but this
is not recommended. Because obviously,
why would we need TypeScript if we just want
to give this any type to anything. So it's
recommended to give type to each and every
variable in TypeScript. But no, I said,
it's not recommended to use any. But instead of
any, there's a much better type that you can use.
So that type is called unknown. So if I go on and
say, person name, if we don't know what type it's
going to be, so we can go ahead and type unknown
over here. And it can also take any type. So this
is recommended instead of any. So just like this,
since we have defined a function over here, and
we don't know what this is going to return, if we
don't even know if it's going to return anything
or not. So we're just going to go and type never.
So what void does is what's the difference been
void and never is void returns undefined,
but never doesn't return anything. So this
is the difference between void and never, I would
highly recommend you to go and have a read on this
documentation. So if I if you go on and search
TypeScript, oops, I made a typo. Yep. TypeScript
and just go on this website, TypeScript, Lang
dot o RG and click on this Doc's over here,
and click on this the TypeScript handbook. Yep,
there is this documentation. So in the basic is
going to go ahead and click on everyday types. So
see any and functions and bunch of other types,
you can see over here, all of the type that is
defined over here. So I would highly recommend you
to go and have a read on this page. I'm going to
include the link to this page in the description.
All right, cool. Now let's get back to this thing
I told you that we're going to go deep into this.
So what is this thing called type. So this type
is something called as alias. So allies are of two
types. One is type, and other is interface.
So let's go on and explore both of these.
So you've already seen this type called type
person. So how do we define this by using
an interface? So let me just go on over here.
And if we want to define a interface, just add
interface over here and just remove this equal
sign. Now it's going to work absolutely same as
this type was working. So now Now, you might be
thinking then what's the point of including both
of these? What's the difference between them? So
let me tell you the difference between them. So in
type what happens is so let me just define a type.
Let's say type x is going to have let's say a,
which is a string and B, which is number. Now if
we have created another such type called type,
y, z, now what if we want to use these
properties from type x inside of this type Y.
So what we can do is just go on over here and
add x. And so what this will do is it's going
to contain all of these properties and all of this
property as well. So if I go on and let Y equals,
and why and assign this, this y type, and instead
of it, if I go on and add C, which is a string,
so something let me just add something for
now. B, which is a number, so you're gonna see,
it's complaining that it is that it is missing
some values, a comma b. But if I remove this,
then it's going to be working absolutely fine.
See, so in this case, we are supposed to provide
it these values this A and B. So type can be
extended like this. But how do we do this in the
case of an interface, so let me just go on over
here and type in a face, like the guy profession,
which is going to be a string. Oops, I'm missing
a t over here. Yep. So what if we want to extend
person in this guy interface, so it's easier
than type, so we just going to type extends,
person. So what I personally do is I like to use
interface a lot. So it makes things a lot easier,
it helps you extend it easily. So if you're aware
of classes in JavaScript, so we have classes like
this, how you can provide the type to our classes
by using the interface. So class name extends
this interface person, but let's just
not get into it for now, it's not helpful
right now for us. So what if this person interface
wants to extend that type, suddenly just remove
these now we can extend these both as well,
if you want to have the properties of person
inside of the x, which is going to do person.
And it's going to work absolutely fine. Now,
if we want to do vice versa, that if we want to
have the properties of x inside of the person,
then we can do extends X. And it's going to
work absolutely fine. So this is how this works.
So let me remove all of this now. Now all
of the basics of TypeScript out of the way,
it's time to start building our React app and
understand how we use TypeScript with React,
state react, hooks, props, etc. So one thing that
I forgot to mention that this app is divided into
two parts. In this video, I will explain you
whole react and TypeScript part of this app.
And in our next video, we are going to
implement the drag and drop. In this video,
we are going to create this app. So let's say
not added to something and some others as well.
Yeah, so in this video, we're gonna build this
simplified version of this app, so that if you are
only here to understand the React App Script part,
you're not going to have to waste your time. And
in our next video, we are going to implement that
drag and drop feature that I showed you earlier
in the intro video. Other than drag and drop,
it's absolutely same, you can edit them as well,
you can mark them as completed, and stuff like
that. So let's go on and build this app. So I'm
going to dock it to the side. Now let me first
convert this function into an arrow function.
So to define the type of this component, first,
let me just hover on it, you can see it tells us
the type definition of this component that this
is a function that returns us JSX dot element. So
this is JSX dot element that is returned by this
function. But what is this function all about?
What is the exact type of this function, so this
is a functional component, right? So we're just
gonna go over here and Colin react.fc. So this is
a functional component. So we are providing it the
type of this react.fc. Now there are a bunch of
other types as well. So if you go on and click CTL
space, and you're going to see there are
loads of types. So one of those types is
react node. So this supports all of the types.
So this can be Boolean, this can be react, dot,
react, child, react, fragment, react, Portal,
null, undefined, and all of these stuff. But since
we want it to be a functional component, so we're
going to type react FC. Now let's go inside of it.
Instead of this, I'm going to type span and give
this a class name of heading. And inside of it,
I'm gonna write task E phi, which is going
to be the name of our app. There we go.
Let's give this thing some basic styles. So if
I go on app inside of app dot css, I'm going
to import a Google font called nucia. Let's go
to google and type neutral font. Here it is.
And the script just click on select this
style and click on Import and take this font
and paste it over here. So let's first give our
app tag some styles So I'm just gonna bring the
styles in for app and heading because I don't
want to waste time writing CSS because this is
a TypeScript tutorial not CSS tutorial. So there
we go, what just just nothing. This is the generic
size, I'm just giving it some width and height
of 100, viewport width and 100, viewport height,
some display flex and flex direction column
so that all of the things inside of it are
aligned from top to bottom, align items to be the
center. And background color is going to be this
bluish color font families the one that we have
imported just a minute ago. For heading, we are
going to give transform text uppercase font size
of 40 pixels, some margin, some color, and their
index is going to be one because we always wanted
to be on the top. Now you're going to understand
why I provided it in just a minute. When I provide
this, the animation so that this doesn't get faded
away in the back, it appears always on the top.
So that's we're going to care about that later.
And some text aligned to be the center. And I'm
just going to give it some media query as well.
That is when it's smaller than 800 pixels, what's
going to happen is the margin of top and bottom is
going to be 15 pixels, instead of 30 pixels and
font size is going to be 35 pixels, that's all.
So let's move forward. Nor do we have dot TSX
and create our input field that is this thing,
this input field. So below this span, I'm going
to create a new component called input field
input. Now, obviously, this component doesn't
exist yet. So let's create a new folder called
components. And inside of it, I'm going to create
a new component called input field, dot TSX. F, C.
Now, if you don't know how I did this, I'm
using an extension called es seven react Redux,
something like that. Yep, this, this is the one
so you can download it and you can type RFC and
it's going to generate this boilerplate. So I'm
just going to type for now input over here and
import it by typing Ctr l space over here. And
it's going to auto import this. Yeah, there we go.
Now let's start building this thing. So
inside of this div, and you know what,
I'm just going to have a form over here, since
it's going to be a form. So instead of form,
and let's say the form is going to have a class.
And inside of this, I'm going to have an input tag
input, it's going to be of type input,
placeholder is going to say enter
a task. And yep, just like that, it's beginning to
take shape. And we're going to have a class name
of input box. So now if you don't know what this
naming pattern that I'm following is, this is
called bem convention of writing CSS class names,
you can just Google it and read more about it.
It's not important right now, but this is bem
convention of writing CSS class, you can ignore
it if you want, and give your own class names.
And now below this, I'm going to have a button,
which is going to say go, and
it's going to have a class name
of what and type of submit. Yeah, there we
go. Now let's style both of these real quick,
I'm going to create a CSS file over here called
styles dot css, and import that file inside of it.
So import styles dot CSS. And inside
of this styles dot css, I'm gonna add
the classes. So let me explain you one by
one. So first of all, for the parent tag,
the input tag, I'm going to have a display
flex and width is going to be 90. Currently,
I haven't given the weight to this input box.
That's why this is not working. But I'm going
to give it real soon I'm giving it a position
of relative because we are going to make this
button inside of this we are going to position
this button inside of it, this input box right,
so we are going to give this an absolute
positioning. That's why we are giving the parent
container as relative positioning and align items
to be the center. Now for input box, just like
this with is going to be the 100% border radius,
some border radius, some padding on top left, top
bottom and left right, some font size some border
you can see this, these are just generic styles,
some transitions so that our animations looks
smooth. Because we are adding the animation over
here, you can see the button animation. Now below
this, we are going to add some focus classes. So
whenever we click on this whole screen goes dark
and only this appears properly. So if I go and
click on this, you can see now what does this
inset box shadow mean? So you can see over here,
this box shadow inside of this, this input box so
this inset is for that. And when we focus on this,
what's going to happen is it's going to provide
box shadow outside of all of the outside part of
this input box. So this is what it's happening. So
focus is focusing on classes used when we click on
this input box. So this is Just basic CSS.
Now for our button that is input dot submit,
we're going to provide this class. So position
is going to be absolute oops, I think,
single colon, so yep, single colon. Yep, just
like that. So currently, the animations are not
working, but I'm going to make them work in just
a minute. So position is going to be absolute,
because if we don't do this, see what's going
to happen, it's going to be outside of it. So
we want it to be positioned inside and right
is going to be zero. So that it we want it to
be an absolute right side, some width and
height, some margin, some border radius,
border is going to be none some font size,
background color, and just generic style, some
little bit of box shadow that you can see over
here below this. So that's all now let's provide
it the animation. So when we hover on it, first
of all, what's gonna happen is, you can see it
glows up. So let's provide the hover class to
it. There we go, you can see background color
gets a little bit brighter. And when it's active,
that is when we click on it, we want an animation
to happen. So transform is going to be scale 0.8,
we want it to become a little bit smaller. See,
just like this, and box shadow is going to be a
little bit smaller as well from 10 pixels to five
pixels, so that it gives us some depth effect. Now
let's come to our main functionality of our app,
that is creating the state for our to do so
inside of app dot TSX. Let's create our first
state. So I'm going to type use state. And
let's give this state the name have to do.
And it's going to have an initial value of empty.
Let's import the user state. Yep, just like that.
Now, we are supposed to give this state a type
since we are using TypeScript. So we are supposed
to give this a type right. So since we have given
this an empty string, let's see what this type
is. This is the type of string so we are supposed
to give this a type of string. If we remove this
and hover on this, you can see the type is now
undefined because it doesn't know what the type
is. But we are supposed to give this the type of
string because our to do will be of type string,
right? So type string, and let me just give it
some initial value of empty. So this is how you
define the string by using these brackets, these
pointed brackets over here. Now what if you want
to accept multiple types of value inside of it. So
just like I explained earlier, we can use a union
over here and give this number. And just like
this, it's going to be working absolutely fine.
So the rules that I explained you earlier in the
video, all of the rules apply over here as well,
if you want to be array, you can add this
like this really cool. Now let's just provide
this to do and set to do to our input field
component. So just like normal react to do,
just like this, we are going to give it but now
it's going to give us an error, because it says
property to do does not exist on this component.
So we are supposed to make it exist on this
component. So let's go to over here. And let's try
to accept it to do comma set to do still going to
give us a binding element to do implicitly has an
any type. So it this thing has an any type. So we
are supposed to define the type to this. So we
can just go on over here outside these brackets
and colon and provide these the types. So to do
is going to have a type and set to do is going to
have a type. So let me just instead of writing it
over here, I'm just going to create it right over
here. So I'm just going to create an interface
that I explained you earlier. So interface,
let's say props. So props is going to have value
have to do and set to do. So we know to do what
what is to do its string. Right? Easy. But what is
set to do, because set to do is a function, right?
So how do we know what set two dues type is? So
let's go back to app dot TSX. And it's easy to
know that if you go on and hover on this, you're
gonna see this thing written over here react or
dispatch now you might not be able to understand
what this exactly is just go on and copy this up
and paste it over here. And now you're going to
see that we have been provided it this types. So
props. Yep, now it's going to work fine. Yep,
there we go. Our app is working absolutely fine.
So this is this is just basically the type of
this set to do, you don't need to understand
all of this. This is just basically the title.
You can just take these from hovering onto this
awesome. So I hope you're having the gist of how
we use this stuff. Now instead of defining the
props over here, what you can do is you can also
give these like this. So as I told you already,
this is a functional component, so react.fc.
And in front of it, we can provide these props
just like this. Whatever you find easier you can
use it. So this thing is basically not that much
necessary, because it already knows that this is
a functional component. Now let's simply go to
our input tag and give it a value of to do. And
on change, it's going to change our to do state.
And when to take an event, e dot target dot value,
now called, let's try to do console, log over here
and see if it's working to do anything. Yep, it's
working fine. Great. Now that to do that, we are
going to create is going to have a few properties
inside of it. First property is going to have a
unique ID. So if I go on over here and create a to
do over here, so this to do has many properties,
it has first this to do property, which contains
this text inside of it. Either one is going to
be a unique ID. And the third one is going to
be is done variable. So is done means if it's
done or not, if it's completed or not. So this
is going to be keeping the track of that thing.
So let's go and create a model for to do
because we are going to use this to do
at a lot of places. So let's just create it
separately. So I'm going to create a new file
called model.ts.ts, not TSX. Because this could
be a normal TypeScript file. So inside of it, I'm
going to create an interface called to do and it's
going to have the properties that I mentioned,
called ID, which is going to be number obviously,
to do property, which is going to be a string,
and is done property, which is going to be
Boolean. Great. Now we want to use it somewhere
else. So let's just export this thing. So export
interface. Yep, great. Now we're going to create
another state, which will contain all of
our to do so we are constantly entering
our two dues over here. So this has to be
inside of a particular state, right? So use
state. And let's name is to dues. And it's going
to be an empty array. Now you might be thinking,
how are we going to provide this that type. So
What type is it going to be because it's going to
be an array of two dues. So we are going to import
the model that we have created to do. Here we go,
it has been imported. So to do and it's going
to be an array, so we're gonna make it an array.
So this is how you create an array of a type or
an interface. Awesome. Now let's try to create a
handle add function, which will add the two dues
to this state. So let's go back to our app. And
I'm going to create a new function over here
const. And add, it's going to take something
inside of it, and it's going to return. So this
is a function over here. Now it's going to take an
event from on submit. So right over here
from whenever we submit the form, it should
add this inside of our handle add. Now let's take
this function and pass this to our input field.
And it should give us an error because this
function doesn't exist. Yep, there we go.
Now we what are we supposed to do? We are supposed
to add this function over here in these props. So
handle add, what is this function going to be? So
just like I taught you earlier, we are supposed
to define a function just like this. So since
this function is not going to return anything,
so I'm just gonna write it like this function,
and it returns nothing. So let's receive it
over here. Yep, just like that. Now, what are
we going to do when whenever we click on this
Go button, so whenever we press submit, this,
this function should fire off. So on submit,
we have to fire off this
handle add function. Great.
Now one thing you will notice, whenever you press
press on go, you can see the page refreshes,
too. So to avoid that, what we do is we go to an
inner normal JavaScript, what we do is we just go
to this function, and we take an event variable
over here, and just write event dot prevent
default. Right? But it's but it's gonna give us
this error. He implicitly has an any type. So we
are supposed to provide this a type. So let's
go on Google and type, event type and react.
TypeScript. So I'm just trying to show you over
here what you need to do whenever you get stuck in
a particular thing in React TypeScript. So let's
go on over here. And you can see it has given us
this type react change event HTML input element.
So we can take this but there is a better type.
Instead of this, let's search it react dot
synthetic event, or there's one more type
called react dot form event that we can use.
Yep, there we go. React dot form event. So all
of these these are going to work. So what I'm just
saying Spending you the best that you should use
React dot form event. Now it's not going to give
us any error. Okay, so it's giving us an error,
because we haven't set this type over there
over into our props right over here. So we
are supposed to define this over here as well,
because we are supposed to define it everywhere
we are sending this variable. So great. That's
awesome. Now whenever we click on this handler,
what should happen is it should set our state
it should set our two dues. So set two dues
to be what first of all, we're gonna check
if there's something inside of the to do,
then only just we are supposed to set that
to do right. So set to do and take whatever
that is already inside of the two dues of this
variable. And we are going to add another to do
so comma, what was the three fields first was ID,
so we're going to generate 10 Random ID for that.
Let's just type date dot now. So this is going to
generate a random ID for this. So now as you can
see, as soon as I save, it's going to complain
is missing the following properties to do and
is done. So let's just add them. Comma to do to do
is going to be to do and is done. Obviously, it's
just created, so it's not done. So I'm just gonna
give this by default false. Oops, data over here.
So date dot now. Yep. So instead of writing this
to do colon to do we can just write to do since
these both are same name, awesome. That's fine.
It's working fine. And now what after this,
after the to do has been created what we're
supposed to do, we are supposed to empty this
input field, right? So set to do is going to
be empty. Alright, cool. Let's try this out.
We're gonna do console log, so I'm gonna
console log to do Okay, let's go to inspect
console. If I click on go, Yep, there we go.
It has generated this array and emptied that.
Yep, there we go. If we go on over here, yeah, it
has created both of these to do with some random
ID is done and false. Awesome. Now let's go on
and render all of these to do in form of this
component, this card type of component. So I'm
going to go over here and create a new component
called to do list. Now, we are supposed to create
this to do list component. But before we do this,
I forgot to do one thing. So if we go on inside
of the input field, there's one problem over here.
So if we go on and type and press enter, so you
can see, it maintains this shadow state. So if we
go on again, and press enter, so it's maintaining
this shadow state. So what's the solution for
that, whenever we press Enter, it should get rid
of this background shadow. So for that, we are
going to use a React hook called use ref. So let's
see how we use use ref with TypeScript. First of
all, we are supposed to add in handle submit.
So let me just write handle submit like this.
For now, let me just render all of those two dues
over here, dot map so that we can see all of them.
So like, you can see all of these to do as
to dues are beginning to appear over here.
Great. Now if we go on over here, we are going
to create a use ref. So if you don't know what
user is, user ref is basically like when we
use document dot get element by class name,
or document or get element by ID, we
are hooking that particular components,
HTML. So just go on over here and type use a
ref. And I'm going to name this ref as input ref,
and the initial value is going to
be null. Let's import this ref.
Just like that. And we are going to
provide this ref to our input tag. So ref
equals input ref. So this is how it works. But how
are we supposed to give this ref a type, now what
is going to be the type of this input tag, so it's
very easy. Just go on over here and hover on it.
And you're going to see some bunch of crap
written over here, which no one understands.
So what we are going to do, we're
just going to take this thing,
HTML input element. So this is what we need. So
if we want to identify the type of this form,
this is the type of deform HTML form element. So
this is a pattern actually. So if we are supposed
to write for div, it's HTML div element. So for
input, it's HTML input element. So let's take this
and just like user if we are going to add it
inside of these brackets over here. So HTML
input element, now it knows that this is an HTML
input element. So what we are going to do to get
rid of this blur, whenever we press enter, so on
submit, it's just going to perform this handle ad.
And what else it's going to do. It's going to take
this input ref, input ref. Now I'm going to show
you what's the advantage of adding a type over
here. So input ref dot it's just a object called
current. So it's showing us this current dot, now
you're gonna see we have all of the function that
we can perform on this thing on this input object.
So we have a function called blur over here.
So we're gonna use blur. So what blur does
is it shifts the focus from this input box,
we have added the blur over here. And you can
see it has already added automatically added this
question mark, because it's not sure if it's going
to be optional, or if it's going to have be having
any value inside of it. So yep, let's go ahead and
try it out. If we type anything in, press enter,
yeah, there we go. It has got rid of that blur. So
this is how we use use Rev hook with TypeScript.
Let's go back to our app dot TSX. And we are
going to create a to do list component, let's
go inside of our component and create a new file
called To Do List dot TSX. AFC, just like that,
is going to be a React, oops, react dot functional
component. And let's import this thing first.
There we go. It is important. Now let's go inside
of this to do list component and create this. So
inside of this div, first of all, I'm going
to give this div a class name of two dues.
And let's import our style
sheet as well. So import
dot slash styles dot css inside of this two dues
div, I'm going to map through it map through all
the two dues. But wait, we don't have the two dues
over here. So we are supposed to bring them in. So
we are supposed to bring in two dues and set two
dues as well. Because we are going to delete them
from this component. So we are going to delete
them and mark them as complete. So we are going
to need set to dues as well. So set to do so it's
going to obviously going to complain because we
haven't defined the, you know the type of these
two dues and set two dues. So let's define this
over here. And face props to dues. So what to
do is was it was an array of that type to do.
So let's import to do first. Yep, just like
that. And it was an array of two dues. Great.
Now next thing was set to dues. Now, again,
we don't know how do we define this thing.
So let's just go to app dot TSX and hover
on this. And let's just take this thing
and bring it over here.
Yep, that's absolutely fine.
Oh, okay. We haven't assigned it. I always forget
to assign props. And let's refresh it. Yep,
it's fine. It just says we haven't imported
it. Right. Okay. So it says that we haven't
provided this to dues and set to dues. So
let's just provide it real quick to dues
to dues. See, this is what I like about
TypeScript, it clearly tells you what is
going wrong. And JSU might be wondering Oh, okay,
is what's going on why it's giving error. So set
to do, it's clearly showing you that what you are
supposed to do next in your application. So let's
go back to our to do list up. Yeah, and let's
start to map all of those to dues. Single two.
And let's inside of it, let's just create
all of this, you know of the card component,
let's create a separate component for this
card itself. So I'm going to create a separate
component called single to do. So for now,
let me just let me just add a list over here
to see if it's working fine or not, to do.to do.
So if we just use remove it and see by having dot
you can see we have three properties ID is done.
And to do. So we need to do from over here. Let
me provide this to lose a little bit of styling.
So instead of styles dot css, I'm going to add
this to do so it's going to be display flex just
like this. So it appears in a similar line. And
when there are more than one to do, it's just
wrapped into another line. So it's not going to
work now because we haven't created those card
component. So display flex justify content space
evenly so that the space between them with 90% and
flex wrap of rep. So let's go in and create that
single to do component of this. So let's create a
new component called single to do dot the SX AFC.
Just like that. Now, if we go back to our app,
you can see we have few icons over here, for
example, this edit icon, this Delete icon and
this tick mark or complete icon. So for this we
are using a library called react. Oops, react
icons. So if you google search react icons,
you're going to find this result over here. And
let's just install this library npm install react
icons and open another terminal and install it.
Now meanwhile, Installing, let's go to react icons
and search and edit icon. So you can see this
is the edit icon that we are going to use that
search a delete icon. This is the delete icons
just like that a tick, or done, maybe,
yeah, there we go, this is the done icon.
So this is what we are going to use. Here we go,
the React icons have installed successfully. Let's
continue building our app. So what are the things
that we are going to send to this single to do
component. So let's go to our to do list
and first of all, import this over here.
Single to do, yep, just like that. So we're
gonna send it this to do obviously, so to do.
And since we are mapping it, so
we are going to provide it the key
to do.id. And we're gonna send it all of the two
dues. So two dues. So all of the two dues are
going to be needed for deleting the stuff and
getting the stuff, stuff like that. So to do.
Now, it's going to give us the error,
because we haven't set the props yet,
obviously. So loose. Yep, just like that. And
now we have to deal with some errors, I believe.
Yep, there we go, we're here. First, let
me receive all of those things. So to do
comma, to dues comma set to dues. And over here,
let's define an interface. Or you know what,
let's just define a type so that you can
get the hang of both of these things, props.
And as you know, in the interface, we don't
write this equal sign, but in type we do.
So first of all that to do, what's
going to be the type of to do
the model that we created. Now second to dues
that we are sending. So what is going to be
the type of to dues are going to be an array
of to do's and then the third set to dues,
it's going to be the type that we
copied over here, just like this.
There we go. Now it shouldn't be a
problem. And let's define it over here.
Just like that. Yeah, it's working fine. Alright,
let's start building our single two components.
So this is also going to be a form. Because
we are going to add the added functionality,
you're going to know why I made this a
form when I create the added functionality.
And instead of this, I have a span with the
class name of to dues single text. So this
is basically going to display the to do to do.to
do, let's see if this works or not. If I go ahead
and press enter, yep, it's displaying that to do.
Now below this, below this, we're gonna have a div
inside of a div, we're gonna create all of this
stuff. This, the all of these icons first icon,
and we're going to keep them inside of the span
tag. So let's give them the class name of icon
to have three icons. So first one will be
fill, edit text, AI, fill, edit. So how
do we use this? If I go on and click on this?
Yeah, so if I go on over here and paste it. Now
I'm going to tell you how you can use a React
icons. So you need to pay attention over here,
what is written at the first two letters. So this
is a I type of icon. So there are many types of
icon. Let me show you import from icons. So
if it go and press slash we are there are
a bunch of types of icon like AI, bi BS CG. So
we need AI, right? So click on this, like that,
and just take this and import it from over there.
See if this should work if I'm not wrong. He
Yeah, there we go. It has generated this edit
icon. So just like that, what we need is AI fill,
delete, and AI. Third one was something else,
I believe. Let's see. So let's take that and
comma. Yep, that's that. And the third one was
MD done. So you can just go on and just search it
over here. And the one MD done. So I'm didn't and
now you're supposed to import it from the MD. So
just replicated. MD done from the Yep.
Oh, yep, it has all those three icons.
Awesome. Let's go on and style these. So I'm
going to import our style sheet over here.
Go inside of the styles. First of all for our to
dues dot single. That is this style, it's going
to have display of flex and with is going to be
29.5 in a normal screen but when we make this
response so as you can see doesn't look good
right now so it will make it better in the
responsive so when the screen size is less
Then 800 pixels, I'm gonna make it full size.
So I'm just going to do that
just in a minute. So after that
border radius is going to be five pixel padding
is going to be 20 pixels inside of it. And margin
top is going to be having 15 pixel, as you can
see, so that it maintains a little bit of gapping
and some background image. So you can take this
background image from the Git repository. So we
are going to find the Git repository, just go
to github.com/push-e O N, inside the repository.
Now search over here TypeScript. So you can
see react TypeScript task, if I just go on
over here. And this is important, you just
click on over here and click on this react
TypeScript tutorial branch. So all of the code
that I'm teaching in this tutorial is going to
be inside of the React TypeScript tutorial
branch. So as you go to src, components,
styles, and the link is right over here, you can
take the link of this picture, or you can add your
own picture, just like you want. Yeah. So next, to
do single dot txt, now we are styling our text a
little bit, this text. So flex one means that it's
going to take all of the available space and it's
going to push all of the content to the other side
of this box board is going to be none font size
going to be 20 pixels. And now this is going to be
used when we make it an input box. So right now I
don't need to pay attention to this. So I can Yep,
all of these icons are going to have margin left
of 10 pixels, font size of 25 pixels and cursor
is going to be pointer steady, you can see our
cursor became becomes a pointer, let me quickly
add the responsiveness to it for our input box
is going to be having weight of 95% when
the screen size is less than 78 pixels
to dues are going to be having weight of 95%. That
is this. And to do single is going to be having
with 100% that is the single component and to
do is going to be the 100 I mean the whole list,
right. So if I save this, see, it looks good.
Now in the bigger screens, the width is going
to be 40% for the single to do component. So
yeah, that's all. Alright, now let's try to
enter more to dues. Awesome. So and if we go on
smaller screen, yep, it's perfectly responsive.
But now, you can see this is not working. Because
we haven't created the functionality for them
yet, for the Edit, Delete and done. So
let's go on and do that. First of all,
I'm going to add the functionality for done. So
on empty done span, I'm going to add an On Click
function. And what it's going to do, it's going to
fire off handle, done function, and it's going to
send it it's ID to do ID. So this handle done
doesn't exist set to let's go on and create it
const handle done, just like this. And you can
see it says that you are sending this to do.id,
but you're not receiving it over there. So let's
receive it over there. So we are going to receive
the ID over here and this ID is going to be
of type number. So now what are we going to
do with this ID, we're going to manipulate our
set to do the state with the help of this ID. So
to dues dot map. So what are we going to do,
we're going to map through this array, and
whichever ID matches with this ID we're gonna make
there is done property of that from false to true,
and vice versa. So we're going to take
to do and we're gonna say if to do.id
matches with whoops, if to do.id is
equal to the ID that we are sending,
then what are we supposed to do? We're gonna take
that to do all of the properties, and we're gonna
change the is done property schema is done. And
we're gonna invert the value that was already
there. So in what to do.is done. Otherwise, we're
just gonna return the to do just like that. Oh,
I forgot to wrap all of this stuff in the map. So
yeah, now it's working fine. The spelling mistake
over here is done. Yeah, now it's working fine.
Now, if we go on and click over here, it's gonna
make it disabled. But obviously, you can't see it
right now, because we haven't implemented it. So
what we are going to do, we are going to check
it over here. If this is completed, then just
strike it off, go on over here. And we are going
to check so to do the current to do.is. Done,
if it is done, then it's going to strike it off.
Otherwise, it's going to render the normal one.
So it's going to enter the normal one over here.
Otherwise, it's going to instead of span just
as that is strike tag, so you can see it
has been done. If I click again over here,
it's not done. Yeah, just like that. Now let's
go on and implement the Delete functionality.
So I'm gonna go over here And
let's copy this up just like this,
I'm going to add it over here. And instead of
handle done, we're going to add handle Delete.
Let's create the handle delete function
right below this const, and delete.
And just like that, it's going to take the
ID, which is going to be a number. Now it's
fairly simple, we're just going to do, what we are
going to do is filter. So set to dues to dues dot
filter. To do if to do.id is not equal to id only
then returned to that mean, if we click on this,
instead of this ID, all of them will be
returned and this one will be deleted.
So if I click on this, yeah, there we go. This is
how it works. Awesome. Now a little complex part,
we are going to implement the added functionality.
So let's go on and do that. So for that,
we are going to create two states. First one will
keep the track if the EDIT MODE is ON or not. And
the second one will keep the value of the editor
to do so you state. First one will be for edit,
which will be true or false. So it's going to
be Boolean. So let's add this type of Boolean.
Also import user state. Right? Yeah. So it
is important that you state so other one,
it's going to keep the added to do text.
So added to do so it's going to be string
string, it's going to be empty by default.
Or you know, it's not going to be empty,
actually, it's going to contain
this thing already. So to do.to.
Do, it's going to contain the to do.to do instead
of it. So whenever you press the edit mode,
the input text input box appears with this to do
value. Just go on over here for edit on click.
What are we going to do? We're gonna check if
EDIT MODE is ON or not. So if edit if Edit Mode
is not on, and to do.is if it's not done. So if
it's not done, so because if it's already done,
then what's the point of editing it. So if it's
not, then only then we are going to edit it,
then set edit to be the value of then set
edit to close, then we are not supposed to
edit it right? Oops, I forgot to do this, or to
create a callback over here. So if it's not done,
then only we are supposed to edit it. Right,
cool. So this will help us switch between the
Edit Modes. So if I go and do this, currently,
it's not going to work. So we have to add an
input field over here and conditional over here.
So let's add the conditional. So I'm gonna say
if EDIT MODE is ON EDIT MODE is ON, then it's
going to display the input box. Other than that,
if it's not on, then it's going to display
the normal that is this part. Okay, an input
like that. What's wrong? Oh, we
are supposed to remove this thing?
Yep, it's fine. Yeah, there we go. If I click on
this again, do this. Okay, we have not styled it
yet. So let's just first create it, then I'm going
to style it. First of all, the value inside of it,
it's going to be this thing. This edit to
do. So What value did you put inside of it?
To do.to? Do so you're gonna see, as I put this
on? Yep, it appears. So let me refresh this page.
And if I click on it, you can see it appears.
Second, we're going to add an On change
function. So on change, we're going to update
this set edit to do this thing. Set Edit to
change, let's say event dot target dot
value. So add the event over here. Yep.
And it's going to have a class name for
us to style this thing of to dues single
text. Again, following the BIM convention
over here. Yep. So there we go. Also,
whenever we press on this when so on change
what onchange will do, it's going to update
the state but what I want whenever press
whenever I press Enter, then it's going to
change the state or it's going to submit it
and change the actual to do so I'm going to
create a handle edit over here and it's going to
be firing off whenever it's submitted to submit.
Edit So it's going to take two things, first of
all the event and the other thing is going to
be to do.id. So this hasn't been created yet.
Let's create it first const and validate. And
we do things first the event,
which will be of type react
dot form event. And other one will
be ID, which will be of type number.
All right, cool. So after this has
been submitted what it's going to do,
first of all, it's going to be preventing the
default behavior so that the screen doesn't get
refreshed. And then we're going to set the to dues
to dues dot map. Inside of it, if the to do.id
matches the ID that is sent by them. That is
sent by the on submit there, what's going to do,
it's going to take all of that to dues. I mean,
all of the to dues properties. And instead of
like, for example, but just just
like we did it with is done,
which is going to update that to do so to do
will be added to do. And if it doesn't match,
it's just going to return this to do that's all.
And after this, it's going to set add it to false.
Just like that. So let's go on and try this. If
I go into hello and press enter. Yep, you can
see it has been edited. Hello, world. Presenter
Yep, it's the editing is working absolutely fine.
So let's first style this so that it doesn't look
ugly. Also, if you remember, I set this over here.
This thing outline if I remove this, you're going
to see if I click on this, you're going to see
this ugly outline over here. So if I remove this,
you're not going to see this outline over here.
Oh, so it was text. And I have worked. Okay.
I've written this test over here. Yep. Now it
should work. Yep, there we go. So yeah, I guess
it's working absolutely fine. But you know,
there's one flaw that I just noticed, if we click
on this Edit button, you can see the focus does
not go inside of this input component, we have
to manually click over here, and then type it. So
let's just take care of that. So we're just going
to again, use make the use of use ref hook. So
use ref. And I'm going to name it input ref. You
can name it anything doesn't really matter. And
just like we did earlier, first of all, let
me import this. And just like we did earlier,
let's take this thing. We need
to go. Yeah. SGML input element.
Yeah, and provide this ref equals input ref. And
we're gonna create a use effect over here, which,
whenever the edit changes, it's going to fire off
this. That means it's going to wait good to do so
let me show you input ref. First Polycom input
input ref above this one. Yeah, so input ref dot
current dot focus. So it's going to focus on that
thing. Whenever this changes, so if I go and press
edit, you can see the focus is already inside
of this. Yep, it's working fine. Cool. So our to
do list app has been successfully completed. But
there's one more thing left that I need to explain
you. That is use reducer hook. So for explaining
user user hook. You know, if you don't know what
use reducer hook is, I've created a full video on
this. My previous video was on use reducer hook,
I've taught how you can create a shopping cart app
by using use reducer hook. So you can go on and
watch that video link will be in the description
or I button above. But if you already know,
let's go on and understand how we can use the
TypeScript with user user hook. So inside of
this models dot TSX, I'm just going to explain
you. So this is going to be a homework to you.
I'm going to explain you use reducer hook and
your job will be to implement it inside of this
project. So let's say we have created a component
over here, let me create a dummy component.
And inside of it, we're gonna
create a reducer by using use
reducer. And as I told you in the previous
video, what we do in user research,
we provided an initial value. So we provide this
initial value. First of all, let me just import it
just like this. So let's bring it down over
here. Yeah, we can import it like this.
And now we are going to provide it a
reducer. So let's say to do reducer.
And it's going to return us the state and
dispatch. Now let's create this to do reducer.
So const to do reducer. Now what do the reducer
take? It takes a state and it takes the actions.
So we need to provide the types to our state
and action. So let's just first write state
comma action. So what is the state going to be?
So state is going to be the array of two dues,
right? So we can just take this interface,
and right to do, and the array of to do. So
this is how we define the state, and what are
we going to keep in our action. So our action
are going to have three things add, add
the to do remove the to do and done. So
it's going to perform three actions. So let's
create the type for our action. So type actions
and go to first action, what is going to be, so
we want them to be one at a time, right? Either
ad can be performed, or remove or done can be
performed. So we're just gonna write like this
side of the curly braces, we're gonna write type,
because obviously, this action has two properties,
right? One is type and other is payload. So type
is going to be ad, and the payload is going to be
a string, because we are sending something to add
something, we are going to send the string from
the input box. So this, otherwise, what's going
to happen is, so let me just write this over here.
Otherwise, let me copy this up. Otherwise, this is
going to happen, it's going to have remove action.
And refer removing, we just need to send the
ID. So we're going to type number over here.
Otherwise, we're gonna do done action. And it's
going to be number as well. So this is how you
define your actions. Now we'll just take it and
assign it to over here, just like that. Okay,
now let's create this to do reducer. So inside of
it, we're gonna have a switch case. So let me just
bring it in. So this is our reducer. Look, if you
have already worked on reuse reducer, then you're
going to understand how this works. It's just to
understand how you can integrate TypeScript inside
of it. So this is just the Add Action, we're just
adding this action like this, the Remove action,
that is just the things that I've already done in
the project. This is how you create a use reducer
in our React apps. So I'm just gonna make it
commented out. So basically, what I wanted to
explain to you is this action type and this state
type, so yep. So now what I want you to do is I
want you to take this reducer, and I want you
to integrate inside of our app. And if you don't
know, how do you do, sir, what just must watch my
previous video, which is on user reducer. Awesome.
So we have successfully understood react with
TypeScript. And let's start integrating the drag
and drop in our application. So let's make the
suitable UI changes so that we can go ahead and
make it look like this. So whenever we enter the
to do, it appears on active tasks. And we should
have a completed task section over here. So let's
go and make the changes in this particular app.
So I'm going to go to to dues list component.
And let me remove this day. And I'm going
to add another div called container.
And inside of this container div, we're
going to have another div called to dues.
Now these two dues, they will be for this
particular active tasks. And we're gonna create
another div for our completed tasks. So I'm gonna
take this div and paste it and let's add another
class over here. Let's see remove. And instead
of both of these, we're gonna add some code,
we're gonna first of all, add this span
tag for the headings. So span.to dues
underscore underscore heading. Alright, and
instead of this, I'm gonna write active tasks.
And below this, we're gonna take this to dues
state that is being passed from AB dot TSX. And
we are going to render all of the to dues
to do. And again, just like previously,
we are going to render our single to do
component over here. So single to do.
And we are going to pass them pass it to do,
and we need to send to dues. Also clarity.
Great, so they should work now. Okay, it doesn't
look really good right now. So I'm going to fix
that later. So let's copy this up. And I'm going
to paste this inside of our to do remove as well.
Yeah, that looks ugly. So instead of active tasks,
I'm gonna write completed tasks. So right now I'm
just rendering this to dues roadmap inside of
this, but later we are going to have a separate
state for completed to dues and we're going
to render that particular state over here. Now
let's provide it some styling so that it doesn't
look this ugly. So go to style dot CSS, and let's
start by changing this width to 95%. And come
down over here I'm just below above this to do
I'm going to add a container class
that we created the container.
And we're going to provide this container
color display flex so that it appears
in one row. So display, flex, some width of 95%.
And I'm going to bring in a few styles so that we
don't have to waste time writing CSS, we're going
to add some margin top to create some spacing
justify content is going to be spaced between so
that some, they have some space in between them,
just like this, some align items to flex start
so that they are aligned to the very start of the
container. Cool. Now we're gonna make some changes
to this to dues. So I'm going to remove this and
change the width to 47.5%, because they are
taking the half of the screen, right, so 47.5%,
and I'm going to remove this flex wrap. And I'm
going to add, I'm going to make them call them so
that they appear in one row. So right now if you
see they appear side by side, so I'm going to make
them flex direction column, some Givens, give them
some padding, some border radius of five pixel and
some background color. So let's see. Yep, that
looks pretty good. And now we should make this
single to do to span the whole of this div. But
first of all, let's provide some to do's heading,
style so.to Do is heading it's going
to have some font size of 30 pixels
provided 30 pixels. Now next for to dues single,
we need to provide it full width already, we don't
need to provide it any of it because the display
is flex. So it's all automatically going to span
it. Yep, there we go. And we are going to add some
transition to it so that when we hover on this,
it grows a little bit. So we are going to add
that hover as well. But first, let me add just
transition of 0.2 seconds. And let's add those
hover styles just like this. So when we hover on
this box shadow will appear of five pixels. And
we are gonna scale it to 1.03. So it's gonna get
a little bit bigger. So see over here. Yep, this
is the animation. Awesome. Now let's come down.
Now we need to remove insert a media query, I'm
going to remove this we don't need this anymore,
because with automatically controlled, but for our
to do is when it's when the screen is smaller than
100 pixels, we're gonna have to do is with
a width of 45%. So let's check it out. Yep,
just like that. Now next, inside of here, in
order to do is I'm going to add some margin bottom
so that it looks a little bit neat in smaller
screens. Also, we need to remove this with 100%.
So that it creates a little bit spacing, and
we're gonna add some container styles to make them
from top to bottom. So we're gonna provide
that container, some flex direction of column
width width of 95%. So currently, it's half of it
around 50%. But we're gonna make flex direction to
be column. Yep, just like this. And also, this
completed tasks should have a background color
of red. So let's add remove class that we added
it. So background color is going to be red. Yep,
that looks much better. Cool. Now I think our UI
is done. Now let's start implementing the React
beautiful DND package into our application. So
I'm going to open a new tab and search react,
beautiful DND. Let's go to this NPM package. And
here we go. We have the installation instructions
over here. And we have some documentation, if
you want to go ahead and read this, you can do
that. So this is how the drag and drop will work.
So we're going to wrap all of our app with this
drag drop context tag. And the place that is this
place where all of our to dues will be rendered,
we're gonna wrap it with droppable. And one
single to do will be wrapped with draggable
tag. If you're unable to understand this right
now, don't worry, I'm gonna explain everything
as we go along. Let's go to our terminal
and paste this. And PMI react beautiful DND
Oh, there we go. It's installed. Let me close this
terminal. And let's go to our app dot TSX. And I'm
going to create a new state for our completed
to do's. So use state comm pleted to dues
and it's going to be an empty array to begin
with. And it's going to be of type the same to
dues type. Now if you're coding in JavaScript,
you don't need to worry about all of this types
and stuff, you can directly just create use
state like this. Now we need to send both
of these to our to do's list component over
here. Set completed to dues also this thing.
Obviously, it's giving us an error because we
because this doesn't exist in our to dues list.
So let's go ahead and add this. So completed.
Again, you don't need to worry about all of
this if you're coding in JavaScript. So it was
of type two dues array. So we're gonna take this
add it over here and Set completed
to dues. Now what? How did we added the type
to this? We just hover on this and take this
okay, completed to dues? Yep, that's fine. All
right, so our app is working fine till now. Now
how do we add react beautiful DND to our app. So
we need to go to our app dot TSX, which we are
already in. So we need to wrap this with something
called drag drop context. So drag, drop context.
And we're gonna wrap all of our app.
Inside of this, now we need to import it
from react beautiful DND. So in port from
react, beautiful DND and just go over here,
press Ctr l space ControlSpace whoops, okay,
it's not coming. Oh, I got it, we forgot to do
one thing, we forgot to install the types for
this particular library. So whenever you
install few dependencies in TypeScript,
they require you to install some types
for them. So I'm going to click over here.
And it's going to take us over here, so we need
to copy this line, or we can simply copy this over
here. And just go back and open another terminal
and just install these types. Because these
types are important for this package to function
properly. Or there we go. It has installed let me
close this terminal up. And now if I go and press
Ctrl Space, and click on this, you can see it has
imported. Now it says an error. So it requires
a prop called on drag end, which we are going to
worry about later, but don't need to worry about
right now. So let's go to to do list. And instead
of our to do list component, we're gonna wrap
it with something called droppable. Because this
area right here is a droppable. area, this area
is also a tropical area. So if I type anything,
okay, so this is going to be a draggable thing.
And this is going to be a tropical thing.
So let's wrap this inside of droppable. So
right below this, I'm going to add droppable.
And I'm going to take hold of this div
and push it inside of it. Now this droppable
is going to have an ID, obviously, it's still
giving that around dragon. So let me just add
this on Dragon for now. Just like this. Yeah,
fine. So it's, it has stopped giving error for
there, there, but over here, it's giving some
error, it requires droppable props. So first
of all, we need to give this a droppable ID.
So droppable ID is nothing but to identify this
droppable zone uniquely. So we're gonna provide
it, let's say to do's list, okay, and inside of
it, we can, we can just put it just like this,
we need to pass a callback, and then we need
to shift it inside of there. So I'm gonna open
a curly brace, and inside of a function, you
can say we're gonna take this div and paste it.
Now inside of this function, it takes a few
parameters. So first one will be provided.
And second one I'll talk about later. So first
of all provided so what is provided going to do
so what did it take this provided and provide it
to our parent div of this particular droppable
zone. So to the parent if we need to provide a
rest, and ref will have provided.in a ref so that
react beautiful DND can control this as a drop
zone. And also, we also need to spread provided
dot droppable props. So that is what it was asking
provided. Dot droppable props. Yeah, that's fine.
Cool. So But still, if you go on over
here and do anything, you're gonna see,
it's still not working, because we have to do a
lot of things apart from this as well. So let's
make this droppable zone as well, just like we
did with this thing. So I'm going to copy this up,
go right over here. And let's put this div inside
of here. And instead of to do list, I'm going to
change its name to do is remove. Okay, now
we need to provide it the function again,
just like we did with the previous one. So I'm
going to shift hold of this div inside of there,
just like that. We're gonna take provided
and we're going to take both of these things,
and we need to provide it to our parent div. Just
like this. Alright, cool. No error, and still
not working. Nothing. Okay, yeah, I forgot
one thing. We passed this completed to dues
so we need this as well. So let me keep them
over here. Comma, set completed to dues.
Yep. So we're gonna take this completed to
dues and replace it with these two dues.
So with this, this and instead of this, I'm gonna
put set completed to dues Yep, so now you're gonna
see, it's not gonna show anything, even if we add
a lot of things over here. Alright, cool. So one
more thing I forgot to do is we need to send the
index to our single to dues component, because
it's going to track which of this particular
to do is being dragged, don't worry, I'm
going to explain it in just a second. So for now,
just follow along, on passing this index as index,
you're going to see how I'm going to use
this. Again, it's giving error because
single to do does not exist, except index
right now, but we're gonna make it accept it.
Alright, now let's go to single to dues and add
the type for index, which is going to be a number.
And over here as well, I'm going to add index.
Great, now we need to make this single to dues as
a draggable. thing. So outside of this,
I'm going to add a tag called draggable.
And I'm gonna wrap all of this form in this
draggable. Just like that, and similarly,
we're gonna add the function inside of this as
well. But let's just provide it a draggable ID.
And we're gonna make this draggable ID, so that
it should be unique, right, so I'm just going
to provide the ID of the two dues to this. So
to do.id.to string, and I'm going to provide it
the index so that it keeps the trap of track of
index. So this is the same index that we brought
from the to do list component. And now inside
of it, let's add our function, take the form
and put it inside of it. Just like this, you
can see, we put the form inside of this. Now,
again, we need to take provided. So you see,
this is just a similar kind of stuff, we just
have to set up few things, and then you're good
to go. So inside of this, we just need to provide
few things provided dot draggable props. So
earlier, we put this thing droppable props,
but over here, we're gonna put the draggable
props, and another things, we're gonna add drag
handle props. And of course, we need to provide
the ref so that it can control it properly.
Yep, just like that. Now, if we go to our
browser, and let's add something. And if I
grab it, you can see it's working. But there's
some issue over here. So if I go on and grab this,
you can see this, this thing is levitating
in the here. Why is this happening? Also see,
if we go over here, it rests over here, but then
goes to its original position. So if I go on and
make this like this, it's not saving the state. So
we need to add this logic. So we're gonna add this
logic later. But first, we need to take care of
this thing. Why is this levitating in the air. So
to fix this, we're gonna go to our to dues list.
And right over here, we're gonna add something
called provider, provided dot placeholder. And
similarly, we're gonna add this over here as
just like that. Now, if I go on and
grab this, yep, you can see it's,
it produces an empty placeholder for that
item. So if I go on over here, you can see
it's providing us the space to be dropped on.
Cool, but, but it's still not saving the state.
So let's go on and write the logic for that. So if
I go on to app dot TSX, you might remember this on
drag function on drag and function. So I'm going
to create this function now. So let's remove this.
And const on drag on drag and, and
let's add this function right over here.
Now this on drag ends, sends this a parameter
called result. So we're going to take result
parameter. And result parameter will be of type
drop results. Now drop drop results. So if you're
coding in JavaScript, you don't need to do
this obviously, but in TypeScript, you do.
So drop result. And you can see, and you can see
it has imported that from react beautiful DND.
And now let's see what is inside of this result
variable. So let's go and log this. So result.
And let's go to our browser, open the console. And
if I go on and drag and drop it, yeah, you can see
we got something. So let's explore this. Inside
of this we have two fields first for destination
and other for source. So what is source source
is something where it came from, for example,
if it came from over here, so it's going to give
this that okay, it has an index of zero in this
array. So it was an index of zero and destination
has where where I dropped it, so I dropped it
over here. So it's going to have a index of one
so it went to index of one in this particular
area. So how do we identify in which area So
remember, we provided it droppable ID, so it's
gonna tell us, it was in the droppable, ID, it was
dropped in the droppable ID and it was taken from
the two dues list. So if I go on and take this
and drop this over here, you're gonna see, the
source is to dues list and the destination is to
do is remove. So yeah, this is how we're going to
implement our logic. So let's find out. So we're
gonna take out both of these things from result.
So result, and we're gonna take out source and
destination. Now what are we going to do with it?
First of all, we're going to check if there is no
destination, if the destination variable is empty,
how is that going to happen? If I, if we
take this and wait, let me just first log it.
Yeah, so if I take this and just leave it over
in the empty space, so we're going to see,
destination is null. So if the destination
is null, we don't have to do anything.
So if the destination doesn't exist, so we're
just gonna return it. Otherwise second use
case will be if we take this and we drop it
in the same position. So if the source and
the destination are same, then also we're gonna
do nothing. So if destination dot droppable ID
is equal to source dot droppable ID, and it's
in the same index. So I'm going to copy this up,
paste this, and instead of Rockwell ID, right
index, so if it's in the same index, as well,
so return. Great. So these were our base cases.
So after this, we're going to declare a variable
called add. And we're gonna declare two more
variables. First one will be active, which will
have all of the two dues in the to dues list state
in this state. So we're going to add it over here,
and the other one will be complete, which is going
to have all of the completed to dues inside of it.
Yeah, just like that. Now, why have I assigned
it to this active, why can't we just directly
manipulate it. So again, when we have manipulated
our active variable, we are going to provide it to
our set to do state. So that will be a more neat
way to do this. So now we're going to check from
where it came from. So we're going to first check
the source and we're going to take it from that
particular source. So if first of all we're going
to check if it came from To Do List droppable ID,
so source dot droppable, ID, if it's equal to, to
do is list, then what are we going to do inside
of this add variable, we're going to take that
particular thing, so active, and it was in the
index of source dot index, right, so we're going
to take source dot index, we're going to take
it from the source dot index, and then we are
going to remove it from that particular place.
So active dot slice, I mean splice. So you can
see what here is splice is used to manipulate
the arrays, remove or add inside of the array.
So we're gonna go to source dot index, and we
are going to remove it, remove one item from that
place, that is that item, which we have taken in
the Add. Now we're going to do this similarly for
two dues remove as well. So else to do is remove.
So if it was in the complete, it came from over
there, so we're going to take it from the complete
and when I remove it from there, okay, cool. So
we have taken that particular to do now we need
to add it to the destination. So SILMO similarly,
we're gonna check if so let me just copy this up.
So if the source dot droppable ID is to
do list, then what are we going to do?
Active dot splice. So now we're going
to add it inside of this array. Okay.
So where do we need to add it, we need
to add it destination dot index. Now,
since we are not removing anything, so we're just
gonna say zero, don't remove anything. But what
are we doing? We're adding it so we're gonna say
add this add variable that we took from over here,
we're going to add it over here. Copy this up
and paste it over here. And instead of active,
we're gonna write complete. And now that we
have manipulated both of these variables,
now we're gonna add it to our state. So set,
completed to dues we're gonna have is going to
have complete and set to deuce is going to have
active. Now this should work if everything seems
fine. Yep, looks good. Let's go ahead and
try it. If I take it and drop it over here,
okay, something went wrong clearly. Oh, for adding
this we need to add this for over here. We need to
write destination, not the source, because we're
checking for the destination, right? Go back and
try to drop it. Yep, it's working absolutely
fine. See, you see how easy it is to implement
drag and drop in a React js applications. But
wait, I need to do one more thing. So if I
pick it up, I should see some indicator that
it's in that drag mode. Or if we hover on this,
they should glow up. And if I hover on
this particular part should glow up. So
let's provide that, I'm going to go to my
code and inside of my to do list component.
So I told you, there's one more parameter
that it takes. And that is a snapshot.
So we're going to take this snapshot, and let's
go to our class names. And I'm going to wrap this
in this curly braces and provide this template
string so that we can write j s inside of it.
And I'm going to open this curly braces
and write snapshot.is dragging over. So
if it's dragging over this, then provide it
the class name of drag active. Otherwise,
don't provide it any class names. Similarly,
we're gonna do this to complete it, as well. So
at backticks, and comma, snapshots snapshot
snapshot is dragging over, then drag, remove,
or probably drag complete. Let's go ahead and add
CSS for both of these, instead of our styles. I'm
just going to make their background color a little
bit more intense. So if we go on, if I pick this
up, you can see if I hover on this, it's gonna
glow. If I hover on this, this is going to glow
just like this. And I want to increase the shadow
of this to do as well when it's grabbed by me. So
if I go on and go to our single to do again,
we also have the snapshot here as well.
And with these to do single,
I'm going to add another class.
So snapshot.is dragging. So over there it was, is
dragging over, so and over here it is dragging.
So we're gonna provide it the class name of
drag. Otherwise, we're not going to provide
any class name. And let's add these styles
for it. I'm going to add some intense back
background Shadow DOM in box shadow. So in 20
pixels earlier, it was 15 pixels if you remember.
So if I grab this, you're gonna see the
shadow has gotten a little bit intense.
Awesome, so you see how easy it is to implement
drag and drop in a React js applications. I
would love to see the projects that
you guys make after learning this.
So thank you all for watching this video. If you
like this video, just give this video a huge fat
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel. Just go to youtube.com/roadside coder
and click on the subscribe button. It motivates me
to create more such awesome videos for you guys.